I can this episode's brought to you by
XO protein that's EXO like the
exoskeleton in aliens and they make the
only bars meal replacement bars or
pre-workout bars in my case that I have
in my house you can hear the crinkling
of cocoa nut which I'm going to get back
to they're making protein bars using
cricket protein powder and many of the
CrossFit mutants and hyper forms are
eating these
I am also eating them generally
pre-workout and I bet they taste better
than any protein bar you've ever had and
why is that just one of the benefits
while they are exceptionally high in
complete protein they are minimally
processed much less processed than most
say whey protein isolate and packed full
of nutrients including calcium omega-3s
and so on for those people who are
interested also very sustainable so this
is part of the reason I ended up
investing in the company the United
Nations estimates that crickets are 20
times more resource efficient per pound
of protein than cows for instance XO
protein was created by a three
michelin-starred chef and two Ivy League
grads they have made a line of protein
bars that will I think really blow your
mind and some of my friends were
journalists have even tested them with
glucose monitors to see what the glucose
response is because they have a little
bit of carbs in them and it was flatline
provoked no huge glucose or insulin
response whatsoever so there you go you
have that they combined the cricket
protein with simple ingredients like
cocoa almond butter and so on to create
a bar that takes just about every box
you could possibly care about their
paleo gluten free soy free dairy free
low glycemic no refined sugar the list
goes on
they are my go-to bars and for all of
you guys listening EXO is offering a
sampler pack of their four most popular
flavors for less than $10 why
all supplies last and that's not an
infomercial while supplies last the last
time they were on the podcast this sold
out in about a week so I recommend you
check it out their startup very limited
supplies go to XO protein com EXO PR OT
ein comport / Tim and you can be one of
the first to try the future of protein
so check it out EXO protein comm forward
slash Tim this episode is brought to you
by fresh books man oh man do a lot of
listeners of this podcast and readers of
mine love fresh books to the extent that
I ended up meeting with the CEO not very
long ago why are they so popular well
they are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of entrepreneurs and
beyond you can take pictures of receipts
you can link your credit card and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier and also in fact
I would recommend a PDF they didn't ask
me to read this part by the way they put
the other PDF a while back called
breaking the time barrier subtitle how
to unlock your true earning potential so
you can search for breaking the time
barrier a lot of people ask me how can I
get a 4-hour workweek with a service
business and the story in that ebook its
PDF is the short answer it's really
really good so I think you should also
check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash Tim and enter
Tim Ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books comm forward slash Tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and I think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job each
and every episode to deconstruct world
class performers from many many
different areas and try to connect the
dots so they may come from chess
entertainment athletics or otherwise
military for instance but what are the
common habits the favorite books the
routines that you can apply to your own
life that is what I tried to tease out
and this episode we have a very special
guest he was highly highly highly
requested has been requested for years
by thousands of you at this point Cory
Booker that is cor why at Cory Booker on
Twitter and elsewhere is an American
politician and the junior United States
Senator from New Jersey now I want to
say right up front I generally have an
allergy to politics and long term
listeners know this I very seldom dig in
and try to penetrate that world but a
few things number one Cory and I
actually go back aways so we've spent
time together second his story is
endlessly fascinating to me for instance
he's faced down death threats from gangs
run into burning buildings and much more
aside from all of the official stuff
that you see and that I think is worth
mining he's also very well-spoken and
very well educated and pulls from many
different disciplines we cover a lot in
this wide-ranging ketchup which we did
in person and Austin Tejas including his
diet lessons from early mentors as an
athletics routines most impactful books
the books he's gifted the most to other
people learning how to quote street
fight and quote in New Jersey after a
road scholarship and a fantastic
education and much much more Cory began
his political career as some of you
probably know as a city councilor from
1998 to 2002 in Newark New Jersey's
largest city he later then served as
mayor of Newark and under his leadership
Newark entered its biggest period of
economic growth since the 1960s the
first new downtown hotels were
constructed in 40 years the first new
office towers in 20 years etc etc he
then won the Senate Democratic primary
in August of 2013 and then won the
general election on October 16 2013
becoming the first African American US
senator from New Jersey I hope you enjoy
this conversation as much as I did I
always enjoy spending time with Cory so
without further ado here is Cory Booker
Cory welcome to the show it's a pretty
amazing being here actually I am so
thrilled to finally be sitting here with
you to have this conversation we met
many years ago and I've wanted to get
you on the podcast ever since I realized
the podcast was going to be more than
drinking too much with my one or two
thousand friends and eyes go and I
myself I loved the drunk taking
questions
oh the drunk-dial episodes yeah great
but but this is one of those moments
where literally when my team my my team
that works with me in the Senate says to
me you know Tim once you have you on
your show it's like this like moment
where I'm like wait a minute
III see this show is sort of like you
having pretty masters of their domains
on this show and the fact that I want to
be under sorry this severe problem of
impostor syndrome like I have not worthy
after a list I'm a huge fan of your show
it has literally influenced my life in a
very significant way as you did in fact
when we met at dialogue we met at
dialogue I was way overweight and you
took the time to stand with me as
everybody left we were at some table and
just coached me for 10 minutes I then
went on to lose it was probably the best
shape I had been in until more recently
but you just coach me I just followed
your gospel and I got myself in shape
and that by that point I was like this
guy changed my life and I just became a
fan read the 4-hour workweek read the
4-hour body my staff just got me your
most recent book so I'm just thrilled to
be here
not sure if I'm worthy oh I think you're
worthy and more than worthy and I have
so many questions that I was waiting to
ask you whether in person just over
dinner or on the podcast so I figured
why not just do it on the podcast and I
wanted to ask you to start maybe at the
beginning because I came into this not
knowing a whole lot about your
upbringing and childhood could you tell
us a little bit about your parents
so I hit the lottery to be born to these
two amazing American
folks who both have tough backgrounds
you know they're black people were born
you know in the in the in the 30s
basically and so growing up under Jim
Crow and my father especially very poor
single mom to a mother who couldn't take
care of him then a grandmother that
couldn't take care of him and I've now
since I was on this great show called
finding your roots
so I actually now know about my roots
going back to the 1600s in America
actually amazingly but well my that sort
of branch of the family my father is
poverty poverty poverty slavery and so
these parents came from tough
environments but both were fortunate
enough to get to a college and through
the interventions of a lot of really
great people especially my father it was
a community of people when his mom
couldn't take care of him that took him
in and bent the branches of my family
towards college and ultimately towards
being middle-income pitched in money I
don't know what their ROI is on those
people that gave like a buck to my dad
to get his first semesters tuition paid
for and then work his way through
college but an incredible amounts of
individual kindness got my dad to
college and then hey great you land in
college right during the civil rights
movement and you got black people white
people Christian Jewish Muslim all
pouring into the south for you to
basically give you equal opportunity in
this country so doors started opening up
the blacks that never had been before my
parents both get to Washington DC after
college and my dad thanks to again the
activism of blacks and whites you know
Christians Jews Republicans and
Democrats who were saying that these
companies kind of gotta start hiring
black people and companies opened their
doors so my dad became the first black
salesman for an oil company first black
buyer I think for a department store
then he became IBM's first black
salesman for the entire Virginia area
and what happens when you let people at
the table to have a fair chance to
compete
he kicked ass excuse me he just sex
thing you know he's like they're top 5%
of their global salesmen and gets
promoted to New Jersey with his new wife
and at that point I was four months old
so we moved to Jersey that's how my
Jersey origins come so I've spent a good
amount of time in Jersey and we're gonna
get to Jersey we're gonna spend a lot of
time on Jersey I suspect what were some
of the lessons or sayings the
you found most impactful or have
retained from your parents well look I
mean the James Baldwin says that
children are never good at listening to
their elders but they never fail to
imitate them so I've learned that my
parents said certain things that I
abided by because that's how they lived
and then my parents told me a whole
bunch of stuff that I didn't embody
because they didn't live in allegiance
to what they told me to do so look my
parents embody this interesting ethic
they were very entrepreneurial people
they were very business minded people
but they also almost felt like they just
had this debt to society because they
knew the extraordinary acts of love and
kindness that got there I mean my dad's
work ethic and my mom's work ethic is I
get older I'm more appreciate my mother
I don't think I appreciate as much as a
young but my father was one of these
guys that would like if it was a snow
day and I'm like in first grade all
excited the first sound I would be woken
up in the morning but 5:00 a.m. my dad's
shoveling the driveway when everybody's
staying home because he was gonna go to
work and be the first person to work no
matter what and so you know my dad even
though he had this incredible work ethic
and climbed the ladder into middle class
you know through the sheer grit that he
had he also had this understanding that
like if it wasn't for lots of thousands
of people you don't even know I wouldn't
be here and so my dad had this powerful
story he told it got more dramatic the
older I got I mean I understand I'm
walking around out by the time I'm 18
years old like I'm thinking I'm the
greatest gift of the world I'm a
two-position high school you know all
stayed the high school football player
all-american high school football player
president of my class I got thinking I'm
somebody my father would look at me and
say you know boy don't you dare walk
around this house like you hit a triple
you were born on third base you know you
you think you're special you know how
many people and I would get the lecture
you know and it was easy for him to do
that lecture because he knew that I knew
that I was very different than my peers
and the sense of I was black is my
father called us we were the four
raisins in a tub of sweet vanilla ice
cream no we were definitely not the norm
in terms of race in the in the town and
so then he can easily tell me how I got
there look when my parents moved to New
Jersey I grew up in the northeastern
County the one that looks at
across the Palisades across the Hudson
River at New York
north of the George Washington Bridge my
father basically is like look what took
us to get here so my parents when they
tried to buy homes in Bergen County
there's only a handful of towns in this
70 town county 70-plus town county that
would let blacks move in and they didn't
have laws at the time people think the
north it was a south it had the
segregation laws no it was real estate
steering like family shows up let me
show you with homes in Teaneck or
Englewood or Hackensack you don't want
to go up here so what my parents ended
up doing a group of just again blacks
and whites joined together to create a
storefront operation called the Fair
Housing Council and they would go with
blacks my parents and send a white
couple right behind them my parents
would look at a house be told it was
sold the white couple would come find
out the house is still for sale and on
this house of my parents fell in love
with one two three Norma Road and
Harrington Park New Jersey they were
told it was sold the white couple came
found I was still for sale why couple
puts a bid on the house papers are drawn
up on the day of the closing my father
shows up in a volunteer lawyer guy named
Marty Friedman a Jewish lawyer who just
on his own time wanted to help black
families out and literally the real
estate agent stands up angrily when he
realizes he's got caught in a sting
operation it doesn't relent doesn't say
yeah I broke the law
no he punches my death lawyer in the
face and and sig's it was a great
response right and puts a dog on my dad
literally sings his dog on my dad and I
always joke that the that every time as
I got older older the dog got bigger
eventually it was like a pack of wolves
son I fought a pack of wolf so you could
eat that tuna fish sandwich it um but
but you know then we move into this home
and and so for me as my father would
like say to me zazz you're you know
you're drinking from wells of freedom
and liberty an opportunity that you
didn't dig you were eating from banquet
tables prepared for you by your
ancestors this is kind of stuff my
parents inspired my understanding to
recognize that if you have the luck I
just had a Senate hearing last week
about Yemen and three million internally
displaced people war it's a country on
the brink of famine which is a not a not
not something the UN does lightly to
talk about widespread famine if you have
the fortune the blessing of being born
an American you are in the rarefied of
rarified airs in humanity
if you're an American in the 21st
century and what my parents did a good
job of sort of bringing fully to my
consciousness through the portal and
lens of the black experience but frankly
I don't care if you're Irish American if
you're Indian American this is all of us
how much effort had to go and it wasn't
Abraham Lincoln and FDR no it was good
folk ordinary folks who just said you
know what I may be Jewish you may be
Christian I may be a black you may be
white but we are in this together and
we're gonna we're gonna if you're facing
an injustice it's a problem with me and
I would here you know you know before I
been studying this stuff in history like
you know Sun people storm beaches in
Normandy for you you know they they
swept floors for you they went on
freedom rides for you and so if any
mantra Civic sort of family mantra that
was there for my brother and I is yeah
you have an obligation to take the
blessings God gave you and work like
work is like the most important thing
like out don't let anybody ever outwork
you and that that's you know I've shared
this in sports or what-have-you work I
think is important but like service has
got to be a part of that too you owe a
debt you can't pay back to your answer
so you got to pay it forward by paying
it to other people see you you played
ball you ended up at Stanford I always
say I got my Stanford because over a 4.0
and 1600 4.0 yards per carry 6200 yards
now I was so you grew up as I understand
it about a mile or two away from a
previous guest John Crowley and so he
suggested that I ask you about and I
know nothing about football so I'm
getting deep into my sort of the the the
deep end of my ignorance pulling ER but
Lou Holtz trying to recruit you haha
maybe you could provide some context for
people who don't even know who Lou
Holtz's well Lou Holtz is probably one
of the greatest American college
football coaches of all times and so I
was in all fairness because the older we
get the better we were at our sports but
in all fairness I was probably the most
overrated high school football player
ever I was just people thought I could
you know part the Seas of linebackers
and score anytime I wanted to and it was
a lot of hype I think
the song back then my public enemy was
don't believe the hype um that was
written I think about my football career
but but I had a choice of going anywhere
and I just looked at it you went to
Princeton and again this this idea that
like okay like I'm have a chance to get
a full scholarship to any college in the
country I'm gonna go as because my
parents wiring to the best academic
school I can go to and so I looked at
Duke can Stanford and UVA and but Notre
Dame was definitely in that list and so
blue halls is probably one the most
persuasive human beings ever and I
always talk about the fact that you know
and in a definitely an embellished story
but going out there and like Lou Holtz
who is a short man as I'm 63 and he I
always say it's like five foot in a
smidgeon and but did like a booming guy
you look up to him right when you meet
him and he just gives me the best cell
you can imagine we actually go into the
Notre Dame locker room and there's my
jersey with my high school number it in
it if you say you're 17 18 years old
like this is amazing
and Lou Holtz goes take a knee and like
when Lou halls does taking me I'm a
Christian boy but I bowed before that
man and then he gives me the best
pregame speech I'd ever heard in my life
I mean he and he pulls from all history
he's talking about you know the Gipper
and and he even talks about Rudy for
crying out loud he goes to Rudy and so
I'm like oh my god I hyped up and then
he goes you know rise cory booker rise
and it didn't take a muscle twitch i
literally elevated up into the air and
after he told me about i'm ready to go
out and chop down trees and then notre
dame you go through this little tunnel
there's a like a four-leaf clover there
or something you hit and i don't care if
you're black if you're you know if you
heard from bangladesh when you touch
that irish but you you the irish isles
call you you feel your Irish ancestry
and still like I am fully baked then I
walk down through the tunnel and you get
on the field and like pulse is still in
your ear it's like as this he's
narrating your moment on that field and
I'm walking down and like Cory Booker
you're gonna score a touchdown to that
end zone so you get to that end zone and
then you turn around and the field is
like a bowl but there's a building
behind the field that's called
considered library I think and on the
field is a picture is a mural of Jesus
Christ with his arms up as if he's
saying touchdown
in fact his nickname was touchdown Jesus
and the only time you can see it so I
turn around and now I don't care if
you're behind Jewish you see touchdown
Jesus after after Lou halts has pumped
you up it is a conversion moment and I
looked at G and I knew what Jesus wanted
from me at that moment he wanted me to
score a touchdown in that Enzo I'm
swearing I'm gonna score touchdown and
so I get home and my parents like where
you going to school I'm going to Notre
Dame and it took them you know
psychologists and the D program need
eventually get me to go to Stanford when
I realized that we played stamp we
played Notre Dame twice in their in
their end zone in my senior year my best
career game was against Notre Dame we
were we weren't even ranked in the top
50 Notre Dame was ranked number one in
the country we were going in everybody
said we were killed by 10 20 points and
they scored touchdown we score a
touchdown we're actually staying with
them and I had this pass over the middle
and Todd light an all-american corner I
have one move in sports and all the
sports he must have not watched the film
but it's basically me throwing my hips
one way and running the other as quickly
as I can he actually fell down and I'm
running towards touchdown Jesus I'm
hearing the I'm hearing the bill the
Lord calling to me this is what I've
wanted from you for your life and I get
tackled from behind by some spawn from
hell and takes me out eventually we
scored a touchdown won the game but my
notre-dame experiences I love the school
and if anything I learned from that
because we had no right to be in that
end zone I still always tell people my
true lesson from that story is that if
you have a right team you can be up
against people that are superior
athletes superior intellect or whatever
but a good team people together can beat
any group of great individuals so ok
that is a fantastic story we're gonna
talk about delegating and team I think a
little bit later because there were some
listener questions about that but I want
to talk about persuasion so you
mentioned blue is very persuasive I
think of you as very persuasive and
you're very gifted speaker and I think
we're gonna take a slight left turn it's
gonna seem that way but it's related we
talked a little bit about this before we
started recording so correct me if I'm
wrong here but you ran a student-run
crisis hotline
yeah at Stanford could you talk about
that and specifically I want to know
what did you learn about that experience
and what works when you are on a crisis
hotline so this is a sort of crisis
hotline called the bridge at Stanford
and it was probably one of the best life
experiences because I was sort of a
teenager going to my early 20s and it
was a first sort of nonprofit I ran and
this collective of other leaders was
five of us had lived at the center 24
hours a day would cover the night in the
other gym when I just started as a
counselor there I'm this eighteen year
old or nineteen year old young man who a
lot of us I don't think get this
understanding that we are we've lived
our lives in our own lane and we don't
necessarily get to pull back the screen
and talk to other people about their
experiences beyond the niceties we
exchange everyday and and I can't
remember who said about you know be kind
to one another because we're all
fighting a hard battle and it might have
been Socrates or someone but it was the
it was basically it punched me in my
square in my nose about how important
the kindness and empathy is because what
I started sitting on that phone and on a
Friday night I was so shaken because we
would have rape calls that I had women
that were there I still remember one
committable named Allison who would do
pick up women that were escaping spousal
abuse and there's another counselor
there name Daniel Bao and other amazing
beautiful human being
I could I just had no idea how again
this is early eighties early 90s how
ignorant I was about gay and lesbian
Americans and how many biases that stem
from my ignorance and sitting down and
and having people calling about their
experiences coming out and hearing
the truth of people talking about
thinking about killing themselves
because they are try not attracted to
someone of a different sex or talking
about the horrors that they experienced
abuses they experience or eating
disorders and and having being in forms
of honest conversation about how just
saying something somebody about a you're
gaining some weight you know something
how comments like that can hurt and and
and or what it's like just growing up in
in in an environment where you where
you're constantly being told that your
worth is based upon your how much weight
you have and so I can go on and on and
on but it was one of those places where
I felt like Sanford's a great I my
course load got great but I learned so
much about empathy and about listening
and about non-judgmental ISM sort of
fundamental core and we literally had a
rule of what the sort of the first five
rules of peer counseling that were about
empathy that were about non-judgmental
ism about listening do you recall
specifically what any of those rules
were some of them were as simple as be
non-judgmental
um and they had something that I think I
literally was talking to one of my
closest friends about that yesterday
because they were going off about
someone who was involved in a protest or
something and how it wasn't sincere and
so on and so forth
and we just don't realize how often
we're casting judgment when we know
nothing about the person we know nothing
about their struggle and we just are so
quick to judge other people and how
harsh it would be back to us and to
actually be taught to be able to be a
counselor or somebody and hold no
judgment of them whatsoever or to or to
suppress that and just be there to
listen and to be to give them empathy
and all these are often tags for love it
was a powerful lesson for me and and so
I guess what I'm saying to you is I I
think there's something about persuasion
that people often go about it as
thinking about how am I going to
convince you to do something and I kind
of think about that from the start of no
it's not about
me and what I'm gonna do to you to get
you to do something it's actually about
me being there for you and opening
myself up to create a safe space for for
me to actually listen and hear you and
and and this has been a hard lesson and
I've sort of you know when I when I was
living in really a tough environment in
Newark when I first moved there I was
living in some high-rise projects which
became public housing I you know more
it's like the same lessons that you or I
think you're meant to hear on your
journey in life you know when you start
getting the same thing over and over
again trying to teach you the same let
the I think the universe or tries to do
it the easy way first but that you know
when you see the same thing comings but
this idea of empathy and now in our
society and you and I sort of touched on
this I'm one of these people it gets
kind of bothered that we've stopped
listening to each other like I can't
write wish I could find this study and I
asked my team to help me find it but
remember being on an airplane reading a
study and I thought it was USA Today
about a public policy position in
education and they they said this is a
democratic position and immediate like
80% of Republicans were against it
didn't even know it and they flipped it
around Democrats were the same way they
said this is a Republican policy 80% of
Democrats were against but it just
shifted by just labeling it Republican
or Democrat and what I have to find out
we're in a point in our society right
now where we just have stopped listening
to each other and stopped and stopped
being empathetic and instead are leading
with that judgment and it and and what
the problem with that is it it disables
us in our ability to come together to do
the kind of things that need to move our
society forward and that's why I think
now more than ever and I say this in my
speeches all the time in America we need
a courageous empathy we really let go of
our own ego and tune into another human
being to really listen to them I may not
agree with that black lives matter in
March they may offend me but we're all
kind of wired the same way so why are
they out there yelling and screaming is
it because they're bad and I'm judging
them or am i taking time to really try
to surrender my own position for a
minute and listen to that person in the
Midwest who was a serious Trump
supporter and try to really understand
where they're coming from says I want to
talk about both and now me I might
separate these two out but the empathy
and the courage
which are gonna be recurring themes on
the empathy side of things so what you
just said reminded me on a micro-level
of what Brian Johnson said to me once
and he described all All Hands meetings
or town hall meetings for Braintree
which he then sold to eBay for I want to
say 600 million dollars or something
like that 900 at that point who cares I
mean it's big number and he said that
when he had All Hands meetings people
were very hesitant to bring up certain
problems and he would stand there and he
would make jokes about himself and
mistakes he had made and wait until as
he put it people would bring up the
pebble on their shoe and he said very
often that's all that was needed to
so-called solve the problem was to let
give someone the space and elicit them
to talk about the pebble in their shoe
and in the case of the of the crisis
hotline what are some of the tools you
used to either make people feel better
or calm them down how do you go about
doing that when let's say even in your
own head you might be subconsciously
judging a situation or making
assumptions are there any particular
lines or questions because you're no
stranger it's a conflict you've been in
a fair number of street fights not
literal but oh I mean certainly there's
a lot of excitement in in the biography
of Cory Booker but how do you calm
people down defuse situations are there
any particular words or questions or any
tactics that you use so there's
definitely a tactic and I want to talk
about that but just to give just to give
more affirmation to what Brian was doing
so I wrote a book the year before last
called United and I wanted to the best
reaction I was hoping for people read
the book and say wait a minute this is
not up what a politician would write
because I wanted to write about and
there's five or six major instances in a
book or maybe actually a lot of more
smaller ones of like this is me being a
jerk I mean this is me being a royal ass
and these are this is a big mistake I
made and I don't mind being a little
vulnerable here because I find that that
vulnerability actually creates a climate
for all of us to learn often I think
it's bad when we create when we put
people on pedestals I think it's so much
better when we miss why like biography
when we see people I think
Johnson was a jerk in terms of that way
he treated other people and when you
Martin Luther King like I Cornel West
Oyster Cult talks about it the Santa
Claus of vacation of Martin Luther King
he was a complex man with flaws and and
I think that makes it more accessible
and real when you realize that so I
think that what he was doing with his
creating an environment where let me
tell you what I did that was really dumb
it gives people a safe space for them to
start sharing and build more effective
teams when you have that kind of
connections but in terms of a tactic for
a counseling which is a tactic that we
all know already those of us who
practice this who have been up at night
you can't sleep you have anxiety and you
open a book and you just write down what
you're anxious about suddenly it
actually held it's a really good way if
suddenly it's real and on the paper and
it's really good a way to get to a point
where you go from the emotional anxiety
of it all to suddenly seeing it in a in
a more objective way not that it still
doesn't have emotional triggers in the
like but you see in a more objective way
I'm sure you've probably done that
yourself I actually very routinely do
something called morning pages which is
effectively trapping that those
anxieties and monkey mind generated
insecurities or emotions on paper so
that I can get on with my day right and
so and most of us don't understand how
in our own lives
something simple what we allow our minds
to do things to us that are horrible we
our worst the most important
conversations you have every day are the
ones you have with yourself that you're
not even often aware of that's a great
way to put it and we're driving
ourselves often insane with these
scripts that we're not even sometimes
they're just a little bit below the
consciousness of the scripts were
running and sometimes when you just take
a pause this is why just breathing in
and out just taking a moment to remember
to breathe or meditation is a tool that
I love that you talk about also but
writing something down so in a
counseling setting often what moves a
person to call a crisis hotline is is
they're at a peak moment of emotion or
distress or worry and and that's where
the
active listening comes in where you
really people have this miss idea about
being a council that they're somehow
going in they're getting great advice I
can't solve your problems but you are
equipped and as if from a person of
faith I really don't believe the
universe puts anything on you or God but
I'm you can't handle sometimes you need
to know the right people go to all right
person to ask but I think what's the
tactic of just allowing somebody to talk
and being a good filter or paraphrase er
back to the person so they're maybe it's
not physically they're rewriting it down
but you're their person's beginning to
hear themselves and be able to sort
through what's going on and make help
them sort of start to see strategies
that they could be pursuing to make
themselves better we all have so much
more wisdom inside of us and we give
ourselves credit for I want to flash
forward and given the momento like
scripting or lack of scripting in these
conversations I'm sure chronologically
it will be challenged but we'll jump
around a little bit we as we were doing
a sound check before we started nicely
and for breakfast today he said I'm
fasting today
now I have as you know it deep interests
in fasting and I thought that we might
touch on a tenday hunger strike and
correct me if this is inaccurate but as
I understand it was to bring attention
to open-air drug dealing and related
violence and so on at some key place us
in terms of what you were doing at the
time and why you chose to take that
approach right so your your your
question is so many things I want to
talk about with you because the whole
concept of fasting and the benefits of
fasting so want to talk to you about it
because I've learned so much from you
about it already and now it's become a
regular part of my practice how do you
fast I'm kidding so I I to take you
through the Tim Ferriss effects on my
life which are many you you are such a
good soul because you make yourself
vulnerable I think that's one of your
attributes you know that you are schmuck
at times like we all are and and you
admit that which is again that makes
makes me feel a brotherhood with you but
yet you have like my father that dog at
work ethic where you're willing and and
also a a willingness to hurl yourself
off cliffs pears my mrr mrr eyes can
attest yeah
and I find and by the way by I'm in a
profession that does not like risk you
know politicians it's like what is the
least amount of risk that I can have
because I don't want to offend anybody
god forbid you have no problems I think
you're good at that but I think that
that's when my best times learning and
we can get back to the 10-day hunger
story cuz this was in a moment when I
take the greatest risks and I just hurl
myself off off and that was out of like
a desperation but I love the fact that
you're willing to use yourself as a -
and embrace this idea that I don't have
all the answers I'm gonna try to learn
something and I've followed you through
a lot of your journeys and learned a lot
myself and hacks shortcuts by learning
from you and so you go to that moment
where we met and talked deeper years ago
it was 2009 I think where you help me
get my physical health back because it's
something I've always seemed to be
willing to sacrifice my physical health
and my own well-being and relationships
this this terrible view I've had to
fight where it's all about the surface
all about the mission but that self-care
I've learned as I've gotten wiser is so
much important it's like Steven Covey's
sharpening the axe like but most of us
forget that so I then went back and
gained a ridiculous amount of weight and
was over like 300 pounds again and it
was a few of my friends talking to me
about intermittent fasting that was a
tactic obvious is a lot more going on
when you're in that moment but it was a
great tactic to use and it was everybody
from a congresswoman to who was hearing
this and a lot of people started giving
me that information it was um it was
Ezra Klein I had a pot I was on his
podcast and we started talking about it
and he was just talking about not eating
until noon most days or 11:00 a.m. if I
remember exactly so I decided I hurled
myself into trying it and the more I
tried it the the I found it so many
benefits to my life of doing two to
three days a week of intermittent so as
they call intermittent fasting 500
calories or less a day and so I can talk
to you about all the benefits I found
but your podcasts about the subject
matter about everything from cancers to
Alzheimer's but more important is Dino
probably that was exactly it but I
remember that you said something all
your podcasts about
stress used to have to be if you missed
a meal like oh god where am i God I'm in
the airport I missed breakfast where am
I gonna get this and how much peace I
have now we're even on days I'm eating
I'm like wait a minute I've gone three
days without eating why am i stressing
over that or just the mind space it
clogs your head about thinking about
food and all the time that suddenly I
get a more zen-like path and my chief
staff who's sitting in here to leap at
me should I say something that he's
unhappy with but he like I on days that
I eat I get that three four o'clock
exhaustion where I need a nap on days
I'm fasting I don't feel the need to
mean that so I can go on about inter
missing and intermittent fasting and I'm
one of these people again like you in my
life there's been moments where I just
said I'm gonna try something for three
months like I've been coming a
vegetarian it was I was a peak athlete
at the time and I just said I'm going to
try this and see what it does to my body
and I stayed with vegetarianism first
and foremost I'd like to say it was for
the environmental ethical my body just
jumped to a whole new level of
performance when I first shifted to
becoming a vegetarian so that was the
first thing that sort of like wow this
feels great but this is something I
tried in my life that has intermittent
fasting that really works very different
than the 10-day hunger strike and you've
inspired me with you said you that you
now do some days just water as you see
me here drinking this green crazy shoes
yeah they're no well they're different
ways to go about it so we'll get into
fasting for a second so there are those
who like Valter Longo for instance a
researcher who's talked a lot about the
fast mimicking diet which is generally I
think it is fewer than 500 calories per
day for anywhere from say 3 to 5 days
and I've tended to go more in the water
fast direction maybe allowing some fats
like coconut oil or MCT oil which is
something that say Dominic D'Agostino's
the PhD who first talked about fasting
on the podcast or Peter Atia another in
that case an ND example but let's let's
talk about 10 because 10 10 is a serious
that's serious commitment right and
right and I don't know like the one
thing you do that I have not be able is
testing your blood and see if you're
hitting ketosis and I listen to all that
and saying to myself
dear God Tim I can't get my blood tested
but I can tell you ten days you're in
ketosis okay but but you have just
before I get into this ten day fast yeah
my chief staff and I were in the Middle
East we were I was I went he wanted to
go to Iraq and meet with you know we're
meeting everybody from the prime
minister to leader the opposition and
we're in Baghdad and I just want to get
there I decide you know what I'm going
to do entire time I'm here just kind of
fast and it was this almost spiritual
sort of experience when you're you know
sort of dealing with real very serious
issues and it but it still I was amazed
at how much energy I had how much
clarity of thought and I and I hope that
as you do with your life and inspire me
to do with mine is that people just try
stuff and don't put it at such a level
on that if you if it's like noon and
you're fasting you suddenly start eating
don't hate yourself and but I just hope
I think it's the kind of stuff we should
do is we should experiment with her
why Gandhi's autobiography what what is
it it's the title of it my experiments
with truth and I think we all should
take things and not just in fasting but
you know I'm I'm a very I'm a I'm a
Christian but you know I think they said
you know what I'm gonna do a little bit
to study Islam I hear all this talks
about Islam let me study it just doing
little experiments in your life to learn
to grow to help understand I think it's
just a incredible way to learn and
actually at the end other end of
experiments that I do with my life I
always find myself better and more
enriched let me jump in for one second
cuz I want to underscore what you just
said those experiments can take many
different forms so it could be say a
three-month experiment with
vegetarianism it could be a one-day
experiment with fasting and obviously
folks listening I am NOT a doctor
neither of us are doctors don't play
doctors on the internet so talk to your
yeah ethical professional but all that I
mean it said experiments can also take
the form and I do this a lot when I
Journal of thought experiments so one of
the more productive brainstorming
sessions that I observed recently was
about I would say group of 15 and the
moderator started because there are a
lot of heated topics so we're gonna come
up political or otherwise and he said
let's start with everyone each person
will go around the room
thinking of one of their most deeply
held beliefs taking the opposite
viewpoint and then justifying it or
explaining why it's correct Wow
so assuming taking one of her deepest
held beliefs taking the opposite and
then actually giving a compelling
argument and this is something that I
believe has the nickname steel Manning
as opposed to straw Manning right now
when Darwin actually did this in Origin
of Species to prepare for the onslaught
of criticism that he would receive he
took he he predicted and preempted many
of the positions his critics would take
did not dismiss them actually made them
the strongest versions of those
criticisms that he could and then
address them in the book so that he
would be prepared and so that was one of
the experiments that I most enjoyed
observing as a moderator to set the tone
which I thought was was really
productive again great and you can't
interview all the great people on this
podcast committing them have died but we
even left clues for this how they
experiment like Ben Franklin he um he's
didn't mean to write his autobiography
he wanted to write a note to his family
about hey this is what I've learned in
my experiments and so he would take one
theme just imagine if we all said okay
today I'm going to look at the idea of
gratitude and figure out through this
experiment
Mark Zuckerberg said okay I'm gonna have
a year where every day I say thank you
to somebody and write those notes these
are glorious sort of journeys Odysseys
to see where it leads you and it doesn't
always do it and you're right they can
be just one moment you know what it's
Sunday this is my day of faith
and I'm going to honor God by you know
not going to the church I go to all the
time and maybe I'm gonna go down into
Camden New Jersey and go to a black
church or maybe I'm gonna go to a lot of
tea no let's stay crazy maybe I'm gonna
go to a mosque or a synagogue just for
just to experience that and and meet the
different people so we get caught in
these grooves and we're playing the same
record over and over again
and just doing one thing different we
may not like it but it actually is gonna
stretch and broaden us and actually
change our as you know this I know
you've studied a lot about brains and
how we work just by changing the
synapses of that normal routine even if
something simple as you both have read
about don't drive the same way to work
every day there are collateral benefit
that brain scientists will say to you
that benefit your life in other ways so
definitely and I'm not gonna forget
about this hunger strike we're getting
to it folks but we might end up in a
more interesting place by taking some
detours but the the name Phil Zimbardo
came up before we started recording and
for those people who don't know he was
one of the lead investigators if not the
designer of the protocol the Princeton
Stan the Stanford Princeton oh my god
let's try English again
the Stanford Prison Experiment Wow which
is profound and many experiments
afterwards this showed how you could
influence a good people to behave in
evil ways or neutral people to behave in
evil ways and there's some really
interesting studies that have looked at
so-called good Samaritans and how you
can impact that of their behavior based
on a feeling of urgency and so on but
the point I was gonna make is that he
encourages people to do what he calls
the deviant for a day experiment and
it's in effect doing something that is
so out of character or so socially odd
that that people will might criticize
you or at least look at you in an
unusual way and the example he gave was
encouraging his students to put much
like I think it's Ash Wednesday when
people will put say hash on the forehead
but do put a mark on your forehead and
just walk around all day and even if
people try to take it off of your
forehead which they probably will refuse
to do that and keep it on just so you
become more comfortable with discomfort
and that could though deviant for a day
could take the form of say going to a
church you would never think of going to
or change your routine in such a way
that maybe I met someone recently who
took and this this is a cup can be a
complicated subject but he routinely
does not give money to homeless people
but will invite them to dinner and have
an entire dinner with his people and
he's done this on as a half-dozen do a
dozen times so let's just say
hypothetically the earmarked for me is
usually Saturday so I do these
experiments and I met someone
technologists recently who's decided
even though he's not particularly
particularly religious he is Jewish but
he's going to observe the chabot and
from from I think it's sundown to
sundown you have a one-day week on the
weekend he's not going to use any
technology whatsoever
because he realizes how dependent he has
become and distracted he has become
based on that hunger strike I promise to
give these first of all when you talk
about stoicism and this idea of dressing
for one day in rags I mean there's such
a power of teaching ourselves to be more
empathetic to people might have
different experiences so I was a
Stanford student who did graduate work
in a sociology and just watching actual
experiments Nayak's pairing myself like
there was a experiment I think you can
still get the video of it where you have
rooms full of different people that all
sit in one cohort a bunch of guys and
you put two or three women in there and
just watch how many times a woman tries
to speak and gets cut off versus a time
the men in the room then they try to
speak and get it and so it made me even
if you do 50/50 in the room it just made
me suddenly wake up and start looking
for that pattern in my own conversations
that I had like it was a really
mind-blowing experience to me the
another study another experiment we did
we wrecked this one we were the
experiments in the room where we altar
reach into a bag and we pulled out a
chip and the chip was yellow green or
yellow a blue or red let's say and it
decided the station we had in this game
whether you were the upper class middle
class or lower class and in this to the
game and the rules of the upper class
were great they really benefited us
where was it but and so we knew what the
game was okay this is like class Society
but we quickly in the upper class made
its laws that protected us and and and
the lower class people but what was
interesting about the game more than
that was that the groups who sat in
different areas the animosities amongst
players it began I mean the anger and
the defensive 'no sand the shouting it
descended into a very bad place to the
point at the end of the experimenters
said okay i want everybody to take their
chips throw them on the ground stamp on
them they had us do a bunch of exercises
to get that purge purge you and so just
like Zimbardo's prison experiment as
well as this i think the group of the
game was called star power or something
like that how quickly we fall into these
roles and and so for me I had this one
experience where I went from living in
affluent suburbia to
living in a housing project can you
explain for people what the catalyst for
that was so it was the parents I
describe to you and you know and you
know I was really affected when I was at
Stanford by working in East Palo Alto
and it was literally it's incredible and
for me just literally you cross these
tracks in the East Palo Alto especially
at that time now you've got a four
seasons or whatever there it's
gentrified in some ways but for me you
know I need to get my hair cut as black
guy there's no place on Stanford's
campus was used to having black hair so
my first time was just going to find a
barber that's when I had hair and you
and me both yeah but but then I started
my freshman summer my first year's are
working in a place called the own attic
Harris community center which Tex lee is
East Menlo Park but it was a similar
community and and I found such a
connection with these kids and I
basically said okay this is my life work
I want to work in cities and so I worked
everywhere from East Harlem to East Palo
Alto I was at Yale helping to run legal
clinics and just felt a kinship and a
connection with what I thought my sole
mission was which was I when I say these
words liberty and justice for all
you know I always say to people before
you tell me about your religion first
show it to me and how you treat other
people well our civic gospel in this
country what are the things we all know
the words the Declaration of
Independence or at least we all know a
lot of those words we know the words to
our Pledge we know the national anthem
but those words actually have power and
meaning and and is it just like
religious texts that we read and then we
go out on Sunday and cut driver off and
flip them off or are we living with
grace that Christ or wherever your
religion is commands and I think we have
a civic gospel as well and we are
pledging allegiance to this ideal of
liberty and justice for all but most
Americans don't know that we have a
justice system that by its definition
treats you better if you're rich and
guilty than poor and innocent because if
you and I get arrested for this exact
same crime I'm wealthier than you you're
a poor white guy from wherever you're
from I can get out I can bail myself out
but you're stuck in the jail sometimes
for months people and realizes some
people say for months so if you really
believe in that ideal of liberty and
justice for all what are you doing what
you do today to live that civic gospel
and so for me each and I can this is
just from my own path what I saw was
that I so benefited from this country
and I didn't have you've interviewed
people in the military which I have this
you and I are both wired this way that
we see people in uniform and just very
drawn to them and have a when you meet
some of the guys we've interviewed and
see what they've gone through and see
what they've done for this country they
have a level of sort of patriotic ideal
that is lived in a way that I revere but
I also have that same thing for people
that take themselves out of their their
privilege and say you know what I
believe those words that injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
everywhere and I'm going to do whatever
I can to commit myself so people you and
I both have friends it did Teach for
America you know what I'm gonna go off
and make a lot of money but for two
years of my life I'm gonna do the Peace
Corps I'm gonna do TFA I'm gonna do
something and anyway I had all these
ideals and I think the challenge and all
of us in our life is to try to live
lives of the best integrity we can or we
live in accordance to our ideals and lo
and behold though Newark New Jersey
flipped the script on me and basically
said to me you think you're coming here
to serve you know I I was a twenty
whatever I was 26 27 at the time do you
think you're coming here to serve you
think you're coming you're help we're
gonna flip this script on you I always
hey got my BA from Stanford but my PhD
on the streets of Newark and this
actually leads me to the hunger strike
where I decided that I was gonna move
into the toughest area and not literally
as I'm moving in was this before after
the City Council no I'm Yale Law student
oh this is yell lost it I got to see a
law student and I start and again I
worked one summer and he's pallette East
Harlem I mean I'm I'm very much engaged
in what I think are some of the
frontiers of our democracy but I never
really been a part of the community you
know a lot of us I would volunteer work
then I go back to my dorm you know and
yeah you know so I just said you know
what I want to live my life I want my
professional life to be a part of a
community and here I am I'm a United
States Senator and I have the privileges
going back to probably one of the
wealthiest communities of all the
Senators go back to median income is
$14,000 per per individual but I live in
a community this blows me away every day
I see
Americans with a fealty to the ideals of
this country literally in the grassroots
or in the trenches of the fight for our
democracy every single day it's I love
when reporters or whoever wants to come
and walk around my neighborhood and see
great people who often are stereotyped
or misunderstood because we don't we
wall ourselves off in America we don't
don't cross it's these lines
unfortunately in our society so long
story short is I move on to the South
hand of Martin Luther King Boulevard in
Newark and I'm moving literally as I'm
moving in my big Italian best friend
from fourth grade guy named Chris Magaro
helping me carry stuff and we come back
to the store my stuff is stolen and and
I'm like welcome to the neighborhood and
the the unbeknownst to me but the
abandoned home I shouldn't say this I
did actually know this at the time but
the Bandon home next to me is where you
see again real great cross racial
section of American life because drug
addiction that had knows no race or
socioeconomic status boundaries so
people are coming into this community by
drugs that I didn't realize I've now
learned a lot more about the drug market
even been one before than when I was
mayor because I went back to write a lot
about this for my book and what that can
interview drug dealers from the 90s
and but the this was a hot place to sell
drugs because one guy who is probably a
guy that should have been in corporate
America he ran the drug operation here
just found a way to get very cheap
quality product and so I had moved in
the middle of this not realizing that I
was in probably one of most violent drug
markets I knew it was bad I didn't know
as bad as I when I went in and when I
actually interviewed this guy in some
the other drug dealers they had set
things up in a way that I mean you know
was I was with a person who was helping
me record a lot of the interviews just
sounded like New Jack city so I'm in the
middle of this and I go with this
arrogance to this to the tenant leader
I'm now living in the neighborhood I'm
thinking haha I'm here you know and
writing on my white knight on my horse
you know and dadada and Newark is just
amazing city that doesn't deal well with
people like Middle East the attitude I
had at that point because miss Virginia
Jones a tenant president sort of looks
at me when I'm telling her how
much I'm gonna help her and and she
looks at me this cynical almost just
like I don't have time for this you know
um and so she did this like experiment
with me where she takes me to hound in
the middle of Martin Luther King
Boulevard and again I'm this you know
yeah law student I'm here to help you
and she goes what do you see what do you
mean she goes what do you see in this
neighborhood and I just described it
just the way I did to you in a whole
crack house and you know drug operate I
described the neighborhood and she just
looks angry and she says you can't help
me she starts walking away I run after
her I grabbed this woman from behind
very respectfully um and I say to her
what are you talking about I don't
understand and she says to me words that
changed my life she says to me boy you
need to understand something the world
you see outside of you as a reflection
of what you have inside of you if you're
one of those people who only sees
darkness and despair that's all there's
ever gonna be but if you're one of those
stubborn people who every time you open
your eyes you see hope opportunity love
if you see the face of God then you can
be one somebody who helps me she leaves
me there you know sort of looking at my
feet thinking to myself okay grasshopper
thus endeth the lesson and I went back
and I just was like okay I'm I'm here to
learn not here to help I'm here to learn
and I sat on this woman's couch and
watched what I just was in awe of people
would come to see her with problems you
know and she would help people with rent
somebody needed a job I mean she was the
held this community her son in the 80s
before I arrived got murdered in the
lobby of the building that I lived in
that I eventually would live in she and
I probably were the two people that were
some of the highest income earners in
there we could have lived anywhere but
she literally after her son is murdered
stayed in those buildings remained a
tenant president held that community
together with the force of its will both
buildings owned I'm living that
neighborhood still but those buildings
aren't there anymore they still have a
reunion every year for I mean think
about this these were buildings when I
lived in them for eight years heating
hot water irregular homeless people or
worse sometimes collapsed I'd walk past
people in the stairwells when the
elevators aren't working wandering
occasionally somebody was alive or not
trying to
to nudge them itse feces in the hallways
mice I can tell you all the challenges
of living these buildings but yet there
was such a sense of community created
there that still years later the
buildings are gone they're still at
Reunion being held and the alumni from
those buildings because of the spirit in
that community go on to do incredible
things like I give like I'm sure you do
try to write checks to the end of the
year to people we're doing great things
one of them is to a guy police officer
from those buildings grew up in those
buildings who still does things and so
that's I had got into politics because
okay so fast forward me and Miss Jones
are and other tenant leaders are taking
on the slumlord that well who
intentionally got convicted in federal
court fighting noble battles but their
residents in that building and numbers
others are really frustrated that they
don't think the city is being responsive
to their concerns and needs there's talk
about running somebody for City Council
you know it's one of those times where
you're standing in the line who
volunteers everybody steps backwards and
you're the person so so before you know
what I'm I'm the candidate and I won the
Central Ward of Newark which if you go
visit me in my Senate office that's the
map behind me that still sits there who
got me into politics this place with an
abundance of public housing
overwhelmingly black and Latino folks
who put their faith in me before they
even knew me because this is about a
year after I moved in the neighborhood
that before they even knew I was unknown
commodity said we're gonna take a risk
on you and the reason why the hunger
strike ended up is because I get elected
in a year later I am at the nadir the
lowest point of my professional life
where I was felt like a failure I wasn't
getting anything done the mayor of the
city who was like if I'm just a novice
in politics if this is like my freshman
year of of high school as a first year
city council person I'm sharp James was
and anybody will tell you this in New
Jersey he was the Grand Master I was a
Padawan Jedi he was a Jedi Vader he was
depending on your perspective
let's give love to people but he was a
Jedi Knight and and and and again we're
laughing and people here might not know
it this period of my life became a
document was a documentary post we if I
got nominated for an Academy Award one
one the Tribeca Film Festival for
audience choice I always say the
ignominiously now as a vegan it lost to
a movie called march of the Penguins so
I always say I make an exception for
penguin meat when I'm eating but but
this was a interesting moment because it
sausages you guys can all mail those to
Bryan Callen a comedian he's the one I
came up with and so my first year
basically sharp James is toying with me
I mean and the headlines are still there
cuz I pulled them to write this book so
I want to show people I'm not making
this up that I was getting my car
ticketed everywhere I when I parked in
front of City Hall with the other
council people I was my phones were
tapped this is stuff that you that
sounds almost funny you know two decades
later but my cell phones were tapped I
wasn't getting anything past my own
community was getting frustrated with me
because we all this effort to get you
elected and so I'm ready to quit I was
like I'm was more effective as a young
the tenants rights lawyer than I have
been as an elected office and on my
lowest day one year later the summer of
1999 I'd been elected in 98 I'm at my
wit's end I've gained weight I have
pound I go to bed most nights with
pounding headaches I'm stressed out of
my gourd I feel like people were warning
me that the police were following me
because I think the mayor might have
seen me as a future threat I'm just
pressing and his in it for him so people
warned me that the police are following
me I'm getting I'm just scared and I'm
feeling like a failure for a as a guy
who so much my life is like been afraid
of failure and now I'm first steps into
my professional career I'm failing and
on the on the lowest day when I'm
getting out voted all the time but on
the city council for my great brilliant
ideas of course people associate just
bow down before I'm being a jerk because
I've once one of moments I infinite
admitted a self-righteous jerk to my
fellow city council people I'm supposed
to find common ground with the past
stuff so I'm making all these mistakes I
get a call from tenant leader named
Elaine Sewell these other high-rise
low-income housing and she basically
says to me it's off the hook up here I
still remember the movie that summer was
a Wild West she's like it's a Wild West
out here there's a horrible incident
where the security guards were attacked
by some of the drug dealers in this
open-air drug market unnhhh eita that
they these buildings sat by a too
highway 280 in New Jersey so it's place
people drive by but never slow down to
look except or buy drugs because it
looks like a McDonald drive-through
people would line up to buy their drugs
so the drug is controlled this area the
security guards were undermining that
they try to light the guard booth on
fire and so she's like you got to do
something and I'm basically I can't do
anything I just professed impotency I
said I can't get anything done what do
you expect me to do she and I start
yelling and I can't even get the cops to
stop ticketing my car how am I gonna get
them to come out there and she basically
says to me like the worst thing she
could say to me and this is not because
of her but as tight a wound she's like
why did we elect you then and at all if
you can't do anything and I was done I
lose my temper raise my voice hang up on
her and now I storm home - and you don't
have this problem I do this might one of
my addictions all I want to do is get
back to my apartment in brick towers and
hang out with my two buddies Ben and
Jerry and just like keep myself into a
food coma and go to bed with cookie
Dexter the self medication no I yes and
so but unfortunately I'm walking past to
get to the my apartment this woman Miss
Virginia Jones the this pain in my neck
this righteous pain in my neck the
tenant leader happens to be standing out
in the courtyard and I literally as I
see her I'm sorry I'm not in a mood for
you Miss Jones I need to get back to my
my apartment and eat my dagnab cookie
dough ice cream because they combined
the two now um and as I try to walk past
her grunting her hello like I like a
falcon would with like a mouse she
starts playing with me she still walk
past me and I'm like you know why and
she goes I turn around stop she goes and
she read me right away she's like come
here and give Miss Jones a hug and I'm
like I walk over and give her the most
insincere hug in the world like when you
say you're still gonna be friends with
somebody after you break up with them
it's like yeah and I try to turn around
and she grabs me by the arm and she goes
to tell me what's wrong and I just got
like angry I'm like you want to know
what's wrong you want to know what's
wrong and I vented on her probably
blaming her a little this is not working
I'm a city you know I'm in this office
I'm not getting anything done I'm
getting it was like the Crimea River
always me kind of speech and then I
ended with what's happening to Elaine
swollen guard inspires and literally
said I don't
what to do I don't know I must have
repeated I don't know what to do like
three times and finally she looked like
a lightning bolt had hit her she
suddenly gets really excited goes oh my
gosh I go I stop like she erased my
scrip and my pity party and she's like I
know what you should do and I'm like you
know what this is kind of a wise woman
occasionally she pulls some amazing gem
out and I'm thinking maybe she has hope
for me I'm like what do I do and she
goes I know exactly what you should do
and I go I tell hey I heard you what
should I do and then she repeats it yeah
I know what you should do and I'm like
Miss Jones I don't have time to play for
play yeah what's the plan man and she
looks at me she leans in and she goes
you should do and I'm like yeah yeah she
goes you should do something okay I'm
like that's it
and if my mama didn't raise me right I
probably would have said some wrong
things to her yeah I storm off to my
building elevators not freaking working
I climb sixteen flights of stairs
practically kick open my door plopped
down on my couch and if you walk into my
office today I still have like the
bhagavad-gita the Koran the Torah the
Bible Bible sitting there next to be in
my apartment I open it up and there's
this passage that most Christians know
called if you have faith the size of the
mustard of a mustard seed you can move
mountains but the next passage which I
didn't know well that point it says but
sometimes you have to fast and pray and
I just thought to myself you know what I
had not I was too caught up in my drama
too caught up on my script that I hadn't
sort of surrendered myself with an open
heart and I decided I was gonna fast and
then the idea started flowing I could do
something and I said you know what I'm
not just gonna fast I'm gonna plop right
down in the middle of the drug market
and and fast and I'm not gonna just fast
and pray I'm gonna get a tenth and
before you knew it my mind just started
kick-starting like this is the problem
most people understand that despair or
cynicism is the worst I think cynicism
just like despair is a toxic spiritual
state agree it like it it it gives you
the inability to see faint hope amidst
glaring problems but it but but I'm
again a person of faith I believe that
we were made
image of a creator and therefore one of
our greatest gifts is to be creative to
think of the new opportunity but if
you're so negative and so cynical about
the world around you
you disempower yourself and do something
about it you're only gonna see the
problems and not any of this right and
you I both have had conversations with
somebody that's in that state they say
they want help but every time you bring
up an idea they just shoot it down oh
that want that because they're not open
to two possibilities so long story short
is I go out there to garden spires
we set up a big tent I apologize to
Layne Sewell literally there might've
been some hugging and crying between the
two of us because we were such close
friends I wouldn't have gotten elected
without her and then I do what
politicians love doing I call the press
conference and I I just said this is
United States of America people
shouldn't live in fear and I announced
that I was gonna stay on this pavement
and fast as long as it took for
something to change and I would invite
people to pray with me first day was
four of us praying and everything and
then I went to bed first night was scary
people courageous people slept with me
underneath it in this what used to be
the drug terror drug dealers territory
people threw diapers on top of us and it
was just a scary night but I woke up the
next morning and a bunch of correctional
officers were there and they said hey we
saw you on the news you're not staying
out here alone and over ten days the
world came out I mean there were
community leaders I mean Newark has such
a reservoir of strength and love and
people poured out but then people from a
suburban mayor from West Orange came out
with his police officers Hospital
started coming out doing health
screenings employers started coming out
doing job fairs people are donating
computers and by the tenth day the mayor
of the city came out and it was so funny
because he came out with prepared
remarks and I it changed he and I would
fight bitterly later but after ten days
of fasting and praying I looked at him
differently I looked at him like I saw
his humanity I saw it that he was a guy
and we hugged and I'll never forget fact
my editor want me to write this part out
because I'll never forget smells the
Powis one of the most powerful triggers
to memory I hugged and I breathed deep
as we were hugging and I smelled him and
he smelled like a family member of mine
I'm like that I was at that point like a
thirty year old he was my father's age
and I smelled him he felt like older
uncles and things
like that we part of it from our embrace
which became the front page of this
section of the newspaper and he put away
his prepared remarks and turn and gave a
incredible speech he made promises that
he ultimately I think he was gonna build
a park in the area that stuff never
happened but it was a beautiful moment
we tent came down and I always say the
change never happens in an instant
you know this even in your own lie
change in your own life something have
to keep it and work at and so that the
world didn't change but I always tell
people that for me the most part one of
most powerful moments of my life because
the problems the gardens buyers didn't
go away and it was something I worked on
until eventually I became a mayor built
a park in the area and all the stuff but
the point I always try to tell people is
the moment the powerful moment the whole
experience to me was the last prayer
where there was now from four or five
people praying and shaking on the first
day now there was a hundred two hundred
people and there was everybody there I
looked at and this is I said this is my
America because there was white folks
black folks Latino folks Asian folks
there was an imam Imams rabbis priests
ministers young old people when they
started praying we're praying in Hebrew
and Arabic and Spanish and I was the
weakest I'd ever been after ten days of
not eating but you know this one fasting
but I think it was also the circle I
just felt such strength such power such
energy like I never felt before
and I just felt like I was connecting to
who we are as a country that ideal of a
pluralist Munem then when we all come
together nothing is impossible and it
was the whole most hopeful moment of my
of my life at that point and and it also
gave me this a new sense a renewed sense
of mission that if if I could find ways
with others to bring people together we
could blow away problems in this country
and and everybody could benefit I want
to ask what you learned from that
because it seems to me and I don't like
when people put words in my mouth so I
don't want to put words in your mouth
but that you found an option when you
thought there were no options right and
I'd love to know how what you learned
from that how it impacted maybe later
decisions you could just say well maybe
I'm making too copy of what you learned
because to me there are a couple of
takeaways if I'm taking notes for those
people who can't see me because you
can't it's audio I constantly take notes
so I'm Sur
going things I'm highlighting things
that a you you also force the mayor to
respond yes right because you were
calling attention to something so if you
couldn't go through official channels
you could use the court of public
opinion right two to four to force his
hand through his font right and I would
just love to know what you what you
learned from that experience they that
maybe became part of your repertoire or
set of options later well so this was my
first experience with lessons that
people have learned a lot through active
as an experience if you could bring
attention to a problem you know
look when Martin Luther King and chains
beveled or Thea cot were fighting Bull
Connor if they tried to fight that
battle alone who knows what the outcome
would have been but he had that fire
hoses he had the dogs and all that but
by their ability to bring attention to
the problem after their demonstrations
and and the story went viral back in a
day where you didn't have social media
but you had you know you had the
traditional media and suddenly the
Soviet Union is mocking our democracy
because of what their what this watching
black kids get bit by dogs people in
Iowa's and they're having their dinner
and saying oh my gosh look at the
humanity of us all we all love each
other or have a reservoirs of love for
each other that once we trigger each
other's consciousness or expand each
other's moral imagination let's just say
that it activates us and so clearly in
New Jersey we set up this society
unfortunately and a lot of this was very
bad policy some of a very bigoted policy
of redlining and decisions by the
federal housing organizations to pack
all this poverty in one area
what is redlining redlining is where it
comes from literally what they did on
maps they said okay this is a black area
and we're not gonna give mortgages and
loans to people we're gonna devalue the
neighborhoods there and decisions being
made about zoning where we're gonna let
certain people live and so you see some
of these maps that are still around this
is like part of our history we're at a
time where or people were starting to
flee urban areas it was it was it was a
federal policy enabled certain people to
move out and get good value for their
homes and the like certain people not
and then it was it was put
on top of that were everything from
restrictive covenants to real estate
steering which my family did to think
about this in New Jersey is a great
example this about lots of states are if
they decided instead of putting a whole
bunch of public housing in one area
would like thousands and thousands of
units what if we took every unit like a
Harrington Park you take four units of
affordable housing we now know that poor
kids same poverty poor kids in
middle-class neighborhoods do so much
better than when you concentrated all
poor kids in poor neighborhoods so a lot
of and and by the way these were over
policies who are like we cannot let
black people out of neighborhoods what
are we gonna do to keep them in and so
that created these ghettos that then
became or where do the jobs go to they
went outside of the communities where
the good schools because remember if
everybody leaves a city their ability to
have a tax base to support the education
system is not there and by the way the
tax base is now disappeared you can't
even a support police officers where
everything so cities start tumbling
downward and then you create laws to
keep people back so I was shocked when I
got to Newark that the surrounding
suburbs with really great schools would
actually hire people some private
investigators to say okay there's a
black kid going to these schools let's
follow them around to see where they go
homes in fact there's a woman I just saw
her again last name Martinez who was a
writer for The Wall Street Journal
education page her family used to fake
address in a different neighborhood to
get her kid to school they were caught
she was pulled out of ironically a
journalism class and and and and forced
to go back and a horrible situation a
lot of felt people think don't realize
that a lot of these problems that are
existing today are not legacies to
slavery
these are legacies to the 50s 60s and
70s and 80s what were going on but they
forget the other a story of America
which is the literally the creation of
toxic zones in our nation so people
don't understand so when they flee these
cities the corporate America was allowed
for years to pollute those cities pretty
badly so in Newark I used to remind
people literally put literally pollute
so now you're a kid growing up in an
environment where you've got lead paint
and you're in your and we have epidemic
levels in Newark as well as other kids
so you and I both know you don't
let poison just elevated blood lead
levels affects your brain where your
executive functioning oxygen carrying
capacity and all of that all of that but
it's not just the lead pain the the air
because now you created cities again
where did we choose to build highways
and roads that that the oxygen is so bad
that you have asthma levels or three and
four times as high in urban areas so
that's not been done yet I remember when
I wanted to try to get rid of the food
deserts in Newark big campaign I just
finally got a Whole Foods we've just
opened got supermarkets but we of us
have also said let's create urban
agriculture we're gonna create acres and
acres of farms in Newark which we did
successfully and got that guys coming
over in prison men and women coming over
prison jobs but we also said wait a
minute we want to dig in the ground and
the state said you can't dig in the soil
it's got too much lead so imagine this
now your air quality your soil quality
and what about the river that a hundred
years ago immigrants from Ireland and
you pick your areas could if you were
poor you could still go into the river
and it was a Commons right you couldn't
get fish out of you could get Clinton we
had lots of clams and the like but now
it is I'm not exaggerating this it is
literally an agent a Superfund poison
with Agent Orange all kind of other
dioxides
from years of corporations to spoiling
the river literally stealing from the
future residents of Newark for and
calling it profits and they're present
and so now imagine this you've got
schools that have deteriorated you've
got a physical environment that's toxic
you have large concentrations of poverty
and then you have something on top of
that which most Americans don't realize
which I mentioned earlier but let's just
understand it call the criminal justice
system this is why I love from the Koch
brothers the Heritage Foundation on the
right to Democrats like me all agree
because of this reality that I now know
from my own experiences my friends in
Harrington Park New Jersey and Old
Tappan high school I went to and I hope
they don't get mad at me for saying this
but we broke a lot of laws okay
drug laws friends of mine on senior cut
day kicked open a liquor store it was
closed they couldn't use their fake ID
so they stole cases of beer got caught
that's Breaking and Entering that's a
felony very little consequence besides
our parents and others may be getting
upset but my friends and I are all going
on with our lives raising families very
different justice
system for doing the exact same things
that you experience in a in many places
in our community our criminal justice
system now is overly targeted towards
poor people at Stanford at Princeton
nobody was getting stopped in for us
coming home and by the way if they did
on from a frat party they would find
drugs no FBI operation right now saying
how are we gonna get those college kids
and break their drug ring when I know on
college campuses from adderall to x2 you
know to these things you can get them
sometimes on a smartphone but in the
inner-city those things become literally
the difference between you making it in
life and don't and in a nation we're
almost one in three adults now has an
arrest record for you and I right now we
get arrested where we are have the means
with which it's not going to change our
lives might change my politics but that
won't change our lives
the problem with inner cities and I saw
this when I went out to Rikers Island
you could arrest you can't even afford
the bail you know I was out in Rikers
and these were kids missing six months
to a year before they even adjudicated
there's a documentary jay-z just did
about kalief Browder who spent two years
plus in jail for stealing a backpack and
most people don't realize it in jail
what we do to kids other countries
called torture which is solitary
confinement talk about life experiments
and we've heard about this is a great
guy you should interview we wrote an
amazing book about what he did with
trying to cope with being and stuck in
solitary but psychologists now conclude
in fact over 50% of the suicides of
juveniles in prisons are kids that were
in solitary confinement over 60% when
kids if you include kids it just got out
of solitary confinement so now you have
a criminal justice so that preys upon
the poor and by the way you and I are
both guys of means but in America right
now there's no difference drug dealing
and drug usage is sort of equal amongst
races in America in fact young white men
have a little higher levels according to
some studies or dealing drugs but if
you're black in America you're gonna be
arrested for that usage 3.7 times more
likely than someone's white so now you
get these poor areas toxic physical
environment designed to be poor because
of the compacting in public housing and
in those certain areas now you get a
criminal justice system that is focused
on them not it not in my town where I
grew up right we're gonna get a rest for
it and by the way most people Americans
don't know that if you get arrested in
America
Mille States can legally discriminate
you I can deny you a job just cuz you
have an arrest even if you were is clear
the charges most people don't realize
that FBI records are so bad that a large
percentage of the FBI background checks
come back wrong I think the majority of
them come back wrong so you may have
been cleared or your charges but that
employer who doesn't you don't even know
they're looking at it thinks you still
had something wrong but the American Bar
Association identify 40,000 collateral
consequences if you have been convicted
of a nonviolent drug offense so remember
to the three last president's felony
drug use they cop to not just some pot
Obama and Bush felony drug use there are
presidents a lot of Congress people the
same but if your kid in Newark you got
caught for a nonviolent drug offense
doing something stupid that we did that
Stanford students Princeton students are
doing they can't get a Pell Grant they
can't get food stamps they can't get
business licenses I had a guy begging me
when I was mayor of Newark why can't I
get a cab license I didn't it was
eighteen years ago and I was just caught
with a little bit of drugs you can't get
a job at Burger King in Newark so I say
let's jump in enough go ahead well the
conclusion of all this is is that you
know that that's sort of what got me
into fighting against a lot of this
stuff and finding like the like the the
concrete of garden spires where I did
the hunger strike learning that you know
if I try to fight these battles without
creating unusual coalition's basically
if I could create unusual coalition's I
can get unusual results and getting if I
can awaken people to the facts of what's
going on if I can appeal to people's
moral imagination um I can tap into a
tremendous amount of energy and it was
if for Newark I had to hacked the system
this in many ways what I did with with
being that the hunger strike taught me
that if I could think of ways to sort of
hack the system and get people to pay
attention that weren't paying attention
before I can I can actually make
tremendous things happen very quickly
and so I became mayor as the worst time
to be a mayor of an American city during
the Great Recession which is a Great
Depression
I had a guy
my friend and I know I say that in my
some of my Democrats friends get mad at
me but Chris Christie is my friend I can
write a dissertation on our
disagreements but I said you're the
mayor of the I'm the mayor the largest
city you're the governor the biggest
state let's not focus on where we
disagree let's see if we can find some
things we can work together on because I
don't want I'm just gonna be screaming
at you from the outside as opposed to
sitting at the table with you and
finding things that at least two
Americans can find six or seven things
we could work together on and just to
pause everybody should rewind that and
listen to the exact wording of that
right five to ten times you think
because it's useful and my funniest
chris Christie story's not funniest but
most instructive to me was when I press
got mad at me was it it was marriage
equality was gay marriages being voted
on something I'm strident about equal
justice under the law chris Christie
stridently against and is being voted on
the United States Senate excuse me this
in the state Senate in New Jersey and I
had a meeting
I didn't plan it this way to schedule
with Chris Christie in Trenton in his
office on the same day all this is
happening so imagine this protesters
outside media outside I'm going in to
meet with Chris Christie and everybody's
thinking the guy who raised the first
person ever raised the pride flag in
front of City Hall in Newark the guy
that refused to perform marriages when I
was mayor because I'm not gonna marry
anybody unless I can marry everybody I'm
marching in to meet with Chris Chris and
everybody's like it's going in there to
give Chris Christie hell really I'm
marching in there with him because I'm
working on a 300 million dollar project
in downtown Newark that had places for
schools that had affordable housing that
I brought together an unusual coalition
unions pledging to me to do
apprenticeship programs for my kids
goldman sachs god forbid because they
were the one of the few people I can get
to get capital for the project
it was amazing coalition to benefit my
city to create jobs and the like and
he's critical to getting it done so I'm
going in to meet with him and I come out
and people the press is like putting the
microphones in my face did you give it
to him on this and I'm like I could have
sat there for my entire one hour I had
with the governor of the state of New
Jersey and fought with him and we would
have changed neither of each other's
minds but by focusing on something and
I'm not saying there's not a time in
place Chris Christie has not been soft
on me on things he disagrees been
publicly heard aside even when I'm
senator he's still publicly criticize me
on things I haven't been soft on him
but in that precious time I had with him
I wanted to get this dagnab project done
so I could get jobs for people who
tomorrow or the day before they needed
to go to work and that was what was
important so this this I think was glad
I didn't interrupt you sorry for
attempting where I was going to go is
exactly where you help me segue which is
something that we we chatted about very
briefly before recording and feel free
to to wordsmith this because I scrolled
it down very quickly but we're becoming
reactive astata vez so for people who
listen to for instance when you were
talking about all these various problems
there are many people in this country
and certainly around the world who fuel
overwhelmed disempowered like it's all
just too much that they can't do
anything and then they become or they
take on the cynicism that we already
talked about as being very toxic and
contagious also how would you suggest if
people care about a specific issue they
want to do good but let's say they have
a full-time job
how what makes someone a good activist
well so it's a great question and I'm
just trying to figure out how to
approach this which is I guess there's
two things they're coming bubbling up in
me and the first is again life lessons
that you and I have talked about in our
past but more you've talked about with
like what I find that that if I everyday
if I get up and I can focus on and keep
clarity on what the mission is what is
my purpose today and even back to the
time I credit my success in college from
failure okay so I got in life does this
to me a lot beats me down to like the
basic elements of my being like you and
I both probably been to that where you
just I mean new work did that to me a
lot just broke I think from our
brokenness it's also necessary to be
broken because that's often when the
light gets in it's like when we're
shining armor and look like that
nothing's penetrating but sometimes it
takes us getting broken down and so my
first brokenness in my post 18 year old
life was getting to Stanford is this big
hype football player and failing and
just like
on the depth chart - the coach had to
dig a little hole and write my name
really low on the ground because that's
how far on the depth chart I was and
just getting into a fight on the
football field I'm not a fighter I'm a
guy that fight meaning punch punch oh my
god yeah I went at it and because you
know often most people I always say this
to kids what I'm saying if you bump into
somebody in a hallway and you're in a
great mood that's just a bump in the
hallway but sometimes we have a lot of
anger and you bump into somebody you
take all the anger from all other areas
life and you focusing on that person and
so I was just feeling like a failure
like in the football field and anxious
and nervous and fearful because you get
there Stanford for a football you get
there like around you know God August
and school doesn't start in Stanford -
like September October and so I'm
fearing this reality that the truth is I
was not the greatest student not as
great as the kids on with these
brainiacs gonna come - and I thought to
myself I'm not competing on the football
field I'm about to go in the classroom
get out get just kicked my butt kicked
by these smart kids from around the
globe who are who should beat Stanford
students I'm an imposter I got here as
an overhyped football player who's not
good enough to compete in school and
I'll never forget the moment I really
was contemplating leaving Stanford
before the school even began and running
tucking tail and running and I pulled
out of my notebook a piece of paper and
just clarified I and basically put
values down statements of Who I am what
I stand for and what I am I trying to
achieve and the goals then became and my
you can talk to my college roommate is
still a dear friend I'd have a
whiteboard up higher college career in
the dorm room in the dorm room and I put
it in code because I don't want people
know what my goals were with my goals
hey I have to ask so what would be an
example of a goal if you don't remember
you could make something up and then
what would the code say so some guessing
it wasn't just like Pig Latin or
something no I know the code would be
like like I was really I wanted it to
transform my body and and so some of the
goals were very specific like I'm going
to weigh this much I'm going to run this
for tea time I'm gonna bench this much
and I'm gonna do everything I can to get
to these numbers so and academically
it's the same
thing I'm taking this course load what
like I'm gonna decide beforehand what
grade I want to get and what I'm willing
to do to get to that grade and I found
in college was this liberating
experience because I realized if I was
willing to and I have a good book in me
if you ever want to co-write this book
how to get straight A's in college how
did you get straight A's in college of
you're a dumb person like I was like a
winning tonight oh yeah because I just
realized you know this everything's a
hack right everything is the strategy
that you have and or how much like like
there's I forgive me my Angela forgive
me Alice Walker I can't remember who
said it and if there's a curse in it but
I'm pretty sure it's Alice Walker sings
I came from Long Island so this is the
quota but if you want to fly you've got
to give up the [ __ ] that holds you down
now the power of that is that most of us
want things but we're not willing to
give up something to get it what I
learned in college it still serves me
now is what am I willing to sacrifice
and my willing to sacrifice and in
college for me that wasn't a complicated
life there wasn't anything that I was
willing to give up for the two things I
wanted to excel in academics and
athletics and so once I realized that
and really got it clear then I could do
it so so what happened to me so why did
I become a a student when in high school
I was a B student well it's simple
because when everybody else went Friday
and Saturday and some Thursday Friday
Saturday night was going to parties I
realized if I do everything what
everybody else is doing I'm gonna get
the same results if you want things that
other people don't have you've got to be
willing to do the things other people
don't do and so I said I'm going to go
to the library for three or four hours
I'll still go to the party at eleven
o'clock or 12 o'clock but I'm gonna do
things that other people aren't doing
study I'm gonna learn little hacks if
the papers do on the seventh I'm gonna
find out who's grading my paper and give
them a rough to quote unquote rough
draft at the first but really the first
I gave my best effort like this is the
best thing I could put together here and
I found out that the TAS would say I say
here some of my ideas could you read
this over tell me if I'm on the right
track and they would then tell me the
the pathway I needed to take to take
that B paper to an a paper I could go
through all the things I did to come out
of a Stanford and be qualified to get a
road scholarship but what I'm saying to
you
more
only going to this idea of activism and
I do this all the time and especially
cuz in politics there are so many forces
trying to erode your moral core I love
putting my chief of staff because we
just went through one of them on drug
imports where we got castigated publicly
we ended up getting to where we were in
a place accordance with our values for
the importation for the rightful
importation of drugs from Canada but if
I didn't know my moral core before that
I would have veered way off course and
so what I'm saying what college did for
me had said if you can focus in on
what's important and cut everything else
out and then find people who can teach
you and what I did there and the joke I
always say is like on the football field
that was guy named Jeff James like this
great wide receiver and I studied him
you didn't know it but I watched what he
did I mean I literally would begin
copying the way he dressed for to go out
on them feel like his towel was a
certain way I watched at the end to go
back in sulk that I was so low on the
depth chart but I started seeing that
the superstars on our team they were
going to the gym whenever else going to
the training table transformed my body
made the California all strength team by
by going in and doing all the extra work
in the classroom what I did as I just
looked at who the smart people and I saw
are smart people have better habits than
me they face it's different places than
I used to sit when I was in class and so
for anything you want to do in life
except for maybe being in politics which
I can talk to you about it was harder
for me then I always look for a model
what are they doing right what can I
innovate upon that they're doing so that
I can find a way to do it even better
and then by the way share with other
people your results tell them tell them
about your story and so on so forth so
let's get back to activism right now one
thing I have to get off the shoulder a
night and I don't want to be a
complainer but but I know and I know
your audience
wonderfully is you have Republicans
listened to Democrats view this is a
wonderful one the greats podcast in
American I'm not just trying to blow
your head up because one of the few
spaces in America where people from
different political parties come to
listen to the same guy and that's great
that that right now and there might even
be some Republic's listening right now
that like God who's good who's he got
this week a Democrat
I usually don't listen to but his Tim
I'll give this guy a shot you know so
this is a wonderful space that right and
left are listening to but let's just
take it from people on my side
aisle who are so upset about Trump right
now and one of things that bothers me
right now is because what we don't
understand is before Trump right or left
why weren't we so disturbed before this
about the injustice is in our country
that Superfund site in Newark by the way
they're super funds in every single
state in the nation Ronald Reagan was
the one last president's to reauthorize
a clean up mechanism for the soup Mitch
McConnell the current leader the Senate
voted for it it was to take polluting
industries into a teeny tiny tax no
difference teeny tiny tax to fund super
fights fun sites well we're now in a
different era where god bless Ronald
Reagan but a lot of things he did we
currently don't necessarily want to do
so that has laps and nobody's willing to
reauthorize it so what's happened to
super funds in America they've gone up
we have more Superfund sites now they're
increasing can you can you reiterate
what a Superfund I'm sorry these are
sites that are so profoundly toxic and
dangerous living around them is
Superfund at super fu and D because we
created as Congress bipartisan a fun to
clean them up we said these are so toxic
and dangerous that we are gonna take
special legislation to clean these up
god bless Reagan for reauthorizing it
god bless Mitch McConnell and others for
voting for it now it's not it's lapsed
now I got into Congress this was a
mission for me because New Jersey is the
number one state in America for
Superfund sites north-to-south and
they're overwhelmingly concentrated in
poor areas and now we have longitudinal
data that we know that unfortunately
children who are born around Superfund
sites have significantly higher levels
of birth defects and autism so this is a
threat to American children and it's
been going on why aren't people more
activated about that I'll give you one
more example and this is a this is a
controversial example because we all
like our bacon but-but-but North
Carolina has 9 million pigs why is that
an important number pigs create 10 times
the the excrement that a human being
does so they've got the same population
of pigs as New Jersey as people but 10
times the excrement what do you do with
that excrement when you have that kind
of factory farming well you new jersey's
waste we put it in human waste we put it
in waste treatment
and stutter that doesn't poison us we
don't get poisoned by our own crap North
Carolina what they do is unfortunately a
lot of these pig farms are located in
very poor areas low-lying areas and
these people who live in those areas
didn't invite this stuff in one I talked
to a Vietnam War veteran leaves his home
to serve in the Vietnam comes back in
this one of these places what they do is
they put all the crap into a lagoons
now just weeks ago I went down to stand
with these people and try to figure out
how I can help them in these lagoons and
then they take the excrement may spray
it in the air over with a what are empty
fields but the problem is I watch I sit
there and watch as the mist from that
stuff floats off the property of the of
the pig farmers and by the way the pig
farmers in many ways don't even own the
pigs they get these pigs delivered by
the larger corporations they have to
raise them for six months and they
picked up the long story short this
community has horrific cases of cancers
and respiratory diseases they can't open
their windows they can't they can't run
their air conditioning and every time
they try to elect somebody it will
represent them the industry the one of
the most powerful lobbies in Washington
is big AG these corporate farms
corporate folks will will just put a lot
of money behind people they'll fight
them and I bring this example up because
no human being could have gone where I
went
right or left sat with these people and
see what they're enduring and their
children are enduring and not been
outraged by it so why all of a sudden
now that we have a new president and I
don't care if it's Bhama or whatever why
have we lost our sense of urgency in our
sense of outrage and the last example
I'll give you is a chris Christie
example and I'm glad I said already I
talked to him a few weeks ago if you
can't find a way to be a friend with
another American I always say patriotism
is love of country you can't love your
country unless you love your fellow
country men and women and your founders
even understood this bunch of very
different people at the end of the
Declaration of Independence they call to
future generations and say in order to
make this country work we have to have
an irrational commitment to one another
that makes even it's it's irrational
doesn't even make sense we've got a
mutually pledge to each other Our Lives
our Fortunes I love this last one our
sacred honor so if you're one of those
people who just because somebody says
your
they're liberal you call them a Lib [ __ ]
and I say this is the stuff I read on
just because somebody says they're
Republican you call them a racist or
whatever whatever whatever then you were
not honoring our vision that uh that
this country was founded upon about that
irrational commitment team of rivals
right yes and so Governor Christie is I
use him as an example I apologize if
he's big listener to this because I went
to go vote in 2008 for Barack Obama in
Newark New Jersey a majority black City
let's just say he was a little popular
in Newark lines around the polling
places I go vote there the woman in the
line I'm rolling deep I'm the mayor of
the city I got officers next week I'm
getting out of a fancy SUV and the woman
looks at me as New Yorkers do love my
city we keep it real it's not like hey
mayor nice day she just looks at me the
first thing she says don't you think
you're cutting in this line now and I'm
like yes ma'am and I waited in this long
line one year later it's a governor's
race in New Jersey I go to vote nobody's
there I walk right in and vote hug the
woman behind the table because she looks
lonely then the the results come out
chris Christie narrowly wins that
election I look at the data if if just
the cities in New Jersey had turned out
a fraction of what they did a year
before and I was tell people then people
are complained to me again I told you
I'm mayor during the most difficult hand
of cards I got a Republican governor who
is now cutting back on funding again New
Jersey as a state had terrible problems
and he just said I'm not gonna fund
cities like I used to
so Trenton cuts off with her their
police with Department I layoffs 12%
then we see the the Earned Income Tax
Credit which is a way for working
Americans making thirty forty thousand
dollars a year to get tax breaks he ends
that system poor he pulls that cuts
funding to Planned Parenthood which
again different people on this phone on
this recording might have different
views on it but for Newark it was one of
the best ways for people to get access
to preventive care prevent unplanned
pregnancies people are saying why is
Chris Christie doing this to us and my
response to them is Chris Christie is
not doing this to you what's happening
is we didn't come out and vote yeah it
is so so what people don't understand
King said this and again nobody's evil
here but he said the problem will have
to repent for in our day and age it's
not the vitriolic words and violent
actions of the bad people but the
appalling silence in inaction of the
good people so can I
for jumping yeah alright so if you were
providing say a cheat sheet to people
listening maybe and almost certainly
people in the Carolinas were thinking my
god that's terrible to my backyard I
want to do something but I fear a it's
too overwhelming be I won't have an
impact see maybe I could have an impact
by down at the time if if you were
providing aside from ensuring that you
vote on the things that you claim or of
importance to you what else
if you view at a training school for
super activists what would some of the
tenets be well that's that's the point I
guess I was trying to make with through
my earlier comments to you which is the
same point over and over and over again
and it's this idea that Miss Jones said
I was overwhelmed I didn't know what to
do and she didn't prescribe things she
said do something in the problem is we
often let things feel so big we allow
our inability to do everything to
undermine our determination to do
something right and and what people
don't get is dead you and I and I know a
little bit of your family history you
just heard a bit about mine what if that
person in North Carolina again my
father's home state said I can't do
anything about segregation I can't do
anything about poverty I can't do
anything about lack of education for
black kids in this town
so it's terrible somebody should do
something about it instead they said you
know what this is one black kid named
Kerry Booker I'm gonna give him a dollar
to go to school that act of love had a
had a literally had a time-space jump
that I am sitting here right now because
a small group of poured North Carolina
folks in the mountains decided that I
can't change the world but I can do one
thing for one kid there's a United
States Senator where he is today because
of those acts and so not one action done
in a righteous cause and look at people
who are hacking our politics money is
one of the most toxic influences in our
politics but yet you just watch Bernie
Sanders run a campaign where he didn't
ask for one corporate dollar not because
somebody he said I only have five
dollars to give somebody so you know
what I believe in that Canada I'm gonna
give five bucks to them well all those
small actions in the
get turned into a tidal wave of action
so you and I I don't know if your legs
but I get appeals for money a lot and if
I can't help I at least let me give a
dollar or five dollars to show I care
about this issue and it's something
important and that's my hope for anybody
listening don't don't
up don't feel powerless ever I mean
Alice Walker says the most common way
people give up their power is believing
they have none we all are so much more
powerful than we realize and and
sometimes if we want to curse this the
world around us because it's not kind
enough or there's too much cynicism
nothing is gonna change about this world
unless we do first
and so if that might just be picking
that might just be doing the smallest
thing like I just did spent this week
reading about Yemen I mean it is awful
god awful what's going on there but I'm
not I can't get mad at other people for
not knowing what's happening in Yemen
but if I say you know I'm gonna do one
thing on my Facebook page I'm gonna post
a little bit more about the near famine
going on in Yemen and I'm gonna give
people one instruction of an action they
can take if we were all doing it out
about issues we care about we would be
influencing each other and so that's
what I'm just saying is is is I've
learned in my life again I got a little
cut off but if you're an activist or if
you're a person what is your life
mission state why is that not clear what
do you stand for
I don't not even telling people I don't
care if your admissions to go out and
make a billion dollars are you getting
up every single day and and at least
knowing what your mission is what your
values are and how you're gonna fight
the good fight is you know it and are
you living in allegiance to that that's
why I always say that civic gospel you
know and that's why I always say before
you tell me about your religion show it
to me and how you treat other people how
are you living in accordance to those
values that you hold that you
intellectually have and and and and be
that kind of activist don't suddenly and
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with suddenly waking up and saying I
reject what's going on but try to be
consistent in what you do even if it's a
small way and maybe I know we're coming
up on time in a little bit but if we
have a few more minutes I mean I was
just going to be reiterate and reinforce
what you just said and perhaps
is the word that scares people off
activists or activism because it sounds
like a full-time job so if we were to
maybe just say call it being a good
person as you define it in accordance
with your values and so on that you
could look at it all
almost like behavioral change of any
type if you if I'm trying to get someone
to change their diet to take exercise as
a new habit I'm going to want them to do
less than they think they can do so they
can build momentum and doing very small
things so no it's not going to be the
gym for five days a week an hour at a
time it's going to be five minutes in
the gym twice a week anything beyond
that is bonus credit diet great fix your
breakfast everything else you can keep
the same so they build them that
momentum and a challenge maybe that I
would issue to people listening is if it
seems too big keep ratcheting it down
until it seems easy and then just make
that your thirty minutes of being a good
person for the week and put it in the
calendar for a week from now and that
could be donating $5 $10 to a classroom
on DonorsChoose in the town where you
grew up it could be educating yourself
for 15 minutes on saying site like quest
bridge which is another incredible
educational nonprofit I'm involved with
make it small enough so that it's not
intimidating so it's easy and and you
that's what the gift you gave me back in
2009 when you tell me about working out
and I think about you and I don't me
again I feel like this is like I have a
little fanboy moments with you but there
days I can't work out and I say to
myself Tim told me just raise your heart
rate for 12 minutes and so from my home
and where I live in the in the Capitol
to the Senate office building is a
little over a mile and I don't know if
this print it I'm telling me right now
it's embarrassing but it's about 12
minute run for me and I think about you
I'm saying like look I I'm missing a
workout because my chief of staff
closest friend jerk over here doesn't
schedule me time to work out I'm like at
least I think of Tim I said at least I'm
gonna get 12 minutes in and and I'm
telling you right now when it comes to
being an activist if you if it's as
simple as this I really believe that
there should be more people being
mentors in this world and I can't be a
mentor myself but I'm going to once a
week on social media post the link to
big
there's an Big Sisters somebody one of
your circle of friends if you have a
more 100 followers is one day and if you
post the data you and I love data about
a one mentor in kids life dramatically
changes their life outcomes if one
person in the next month that you do
that or two months that you do that once
a week or whatever one person is a
mentor you just help to change
somebody's life yeah and so that's how
much power you have you don't even give
the ten dollars to two Big Brothers Big
Sisters and so that's what I'm saying if
there's so much we could do that we just
don't do because we don't understand and
with this power you know I'm holding up
my smartphone right now that we have to
connect to people I found this out as a
political scientist that they're more
powerful than one of my political ads
trying to get somebody to do something
is someone posting information to their
friends it affects behavior more than we
know so just a few very quick closing
questions because I we could talk for
hours and hours and hours and maybe
we'll be able to do a round two because
I know we have a lot of listener
questions which some of which were
really fantastic and I apologize to
people we're not going to get to
delegating today we will get to it some
other time hopefully but what are some
books that you have gifted the most to
other people so I have gifted your book
a lot and I shouldn't say it wasn't the
4-hour workweek
I think book of yours so I did gift
anyone was a 4-hour body I just thought
that that there were so many great
little hacks in there
some of them rated our family as I
realized as I was handing to attend well
that's why it was taking that a copy it
also apparently it just printed in such
a way that it flips open to some pretty
explicit diagrams yeah yeah those who
enjoy adult recreation also useful
morning that is and I'm not just again I
shouldn't maybe I shouldn't even waste
my time saying because most of these
people probably mostly good folks who
listen to you probably have already
listened to that so look I thought just
mercy this book written by one of the
greatest American heroes that I know a
guy named Brian Stevenson it was a death
penalty defender and and I try to
consume as much as I can so I do a lot
of listening to books yeah and that was
one of the biggest books that I handed
out us.just mercy back in in 2015 it is
a beautiful listen and it's one of those
books that is a
really good story and it takes you out
of your where you probably are and lets
you look into a window of aspects of our
of our society that are really important
try think of other books I'm actually
going to open up my audible oh you know
what a book I loved a buddy of mine
wrote this book and just for guys who
and men and women I should say that want
to just work out a lot the book about
living with a Navy SEAL do you know what
book I'm talking about how you know I do
know of the book and a blanking on a
title living with a seal that's what it
is and it's Jesse its lair who's just a
if you are workout guy and it was it
reminds me of things you already know
that you can push your body and yourself
far further than you think and it really
was a moment it was actually right I
think I listened to that around the time
I was starting to battle back into shape
from being the heaviest I ever was and
it was a suit it was a wonderful book
and he's going on to write to write more
books like that I'm just going through
some more of these that are not sort of
I listen to a lot of history and
biography so if you were to suggest
people to start with one biography if
they if if they'd like to get into
biographies but are not sure where to
start so I think that well I think
Gandhi's autobiography is profound read
I think that parting the waters is one
of the best Taylor branches pull a
Pulitzer prize-winning book if you're an
American it's just a unbelievable story
of our of our country question that you
wish more people would ask themselves or
that you wish people would ask
themselves more often any any question
that you wish people would ask well
right it's it's productive for me to do
a recent during a lot and you know I
think I even brought this up to Matt
who's I can - oh forget relating to
about like in this context we were
deciding whether to do an grant an
interview that it's kind of a quirky
request that we got and and it was so
easy for me to fall back on okay well
wait why am I here in the Senate what is
my mission and so I do really think
that's a really productive thing if you
have an hour just to sit with an open
notebook and just say
what am I about who or what do I stand
for or what are my most important values
and if you actually can do that and then
then actually have an honest
conversation about what am i living in
accordance to my highest values what
legacy do I want to leave what what
energy do I want to leave on this
universe you know I sat down with and
now I feel like I'm doing more
name-dropping but a guy I review your
name Neil deGrasse Tyson Neil deGrasse
Tyson brilliant guy really a guy you've
had him on the podcast I've had one Neil
Neil you should really come people would
really benefit from you talk about a guy
who's nonpartisan I mean he's a guy that
would give you that let lecture about go
where the science leads you whether it's
left or right but he because I've heard
him talk in ways it ticks off if you're
ticking off both sides of the Pahlavi
you're you're probably doing pretty good
but he's he says we had this
conversation because I love again I love
talking about things from a spiritual
perspective and and but I'm now finding
that science and religion are really the
frontiers of science really are very
spiritual and so an astrophysics I
wanted to confirm this with me because I
was using it in like major speeches
talking about you know stars are
millions if not hundreds of millions of
light years away that's what I want to
confirm with him and I had always heard
that we're looking at stars at night
that had have disappeared but because
your light goes on in perpetuity we see
those stars as if they're there but
they're really gone and so he confirmed
all of that and I said well that's
powerful that a being of energy could be
gone millions of years ago but we're
still basking in its light marveling at
its glory feeling its warmth and I said
we are beings of energy too and so this
idea that the energy we give off while
we're alive this idea that it dissipates
or dis no I'm sorry I am basking in the
warmth of those men on on the beaches of
Normandy as my dad might say I'm basking
in the warmth of those people who helped
my family buy our first house and you've
got to see yourself as no good deed
doesn't resonate but the problem is we
all shrink ourselves fear shrinks
ourselves bigotry hatred shrinks
ourselves negativity but what makes us
bigger and bolder is courage and
kindness and we get radiant when we live
when those values so what are your moral
values
and and are you living by your highest
most luminescent a self and what makes
you and understand what your triggers
are when do you get small when do you
get petty and what have you I think that
kind of self work really helps you be
more effective in living out your
mission but you know that and I this if
people get on if I got in my car and
didn't know where I was going I would
just waste energy race fuel and
what-have-you but if you have a if you
know like a laser beam where you're
supposed to be headed if you've taken
the time to do that work when the
craziness of life you can easily fall
back okay why am I here as a senator why
am I here
as an entrepreneur what what values am i
trying to do and I think we've lost that
capitalism is a great example as a guy
who loves a free market capitalism got
lost when we were allowing people and in
a very unfree market way to voice their
costs off one society like most people
don't realize that a person working at
an IHOP in Newark is you were
subsidizing that IHOP by giving that
because I have friends that work at IHOP
that live in public housing
that's taxpayers subsidizing it's it's
it's outsourcing the costs of paying
somebody a living wage to the rest of
people in society most people don't
understand that capitalism if you really
read Adam Smith he has his moral
sentiments he really talks about the
larger vision this is again amis a
Democrat the head of AEI is a guy that
talks about we as Americans don't
believe capitalism and free markets are
the end we believe it's a pathway to
reaching the free market and and so what
I'm saying is is if we remember why we
have capital and this is why I love
people who get perverted in their
corporate goals where it's just about
that quarterly report well if you look
at the first entreprenuer entrepreneurs
in America they weren't looking at
short-term views of their company we've
allowed a lot of things to erode our
moral compass and make us smaller and
greater because we don't reset what are
we really about as a society why did we
form as a nation what are our guiding
principles and live in more accordance
to those last question do you have any
ask of the audience something you wish
the people listening would would do or
think about and where can people find
you say hello learn more about what you
are up to
I mean the easiest way to find me so is
if you have social media platforms is at
Cory Booker cor YP oh okay you are on
any platform Twitter Facebook Instagram
and I try to do my best to live sort of
my authenticity on those on those
positions on those platforms and I guess
my um request from people which is tough
today because I think that I do worry
about the divisions in our nation and
and I and if I'm worrying about
something I'm trying to do something
myself to heal those and that's why when
I went to the Senate I told my state I'm
not going down as a Democratic senator
I'm going down as a senator for our
state and I'm gonna listen to Bill
Bradley one of my mentors to try to do
everything I can to create working
relationships with my senators so if
Republican senators like Deb Fischer who
she and I've done such good work
together senators like Tim Scott
Republican from South Carolina done
really good work together Rand Paul
who's a guy people would wouldn't
imagine but he and I have done really
good work together and and I guess I'm
saying that as a preamble to say this
it's a shame that in our society we're
creating divisions that are so deep
between us that we fail to see each
other or hear each other back to how we
started about non-judgmental ism and
leading with empathy with a courageous
empathy and and so my request for people
is my first one of my first mentors in
Newark this amazing tenant leader led
the longest rent strike in our city's
history back in the 70s against he won
against the government it was public
housing he let people in this amazing
ryse right this crotchety you look at
him he's you know he not dressed in
fancy clothes and but I watched him at
tenant meetings he's lean you and I both
been weathered or meetings whatever
everybody's once their moment and they
speak for too long but I watched this
guy just look at everybody with these
eyes that he was listening to you and
while I'm getting nudging and tired he's
still looking at people and the irony of
his sight was that he went blind and yet
he would tease me every time I've seen
my day Frank it's Cory's like I see you
anyway I want to end with my request to
everyone and you know and if
what I hope to share with some of the
students I'm gonna speak to in a
commensal speech in a couple months his
last words to me were I walk into his
room he's in hospice and my ego which I
need to check is upset I'm like this guy
tens of thousands of human beings had
hot heat in hot water or state in their
homes why is he dying without crowds of
people I mean this guy taught me that
that significance is more important than
celebrity that purpose is more important
than popularity he lived a life of great
purpose and great significance and I'm
and I go into his hospice room after the
nurses have told me that it's not gonna
be long and he can barely talk and he's
got I don't hope many people have not
heard people tour tend their lives I saw
this with my father and others had
something your breath gets really short
and and but he had he was aware enough
to know that I came in the room and I
announced myself and he forces out these
words that used to be what he was to
tease me he goes I say hey Frank it's
Cory he's like I see you and I said time
with him hugged him and kissed him on
the forehead right before I left and I
said to him um I love you Frank and his
last words to me were I love you and and
I think about that those I see you I
love you I see you I love you we have
lost our way in a in a sense in in in in
America at least many of us and maybe
I'll implicate myself that we think the
highest calling of this country is
tolerance that we are where were a
nation of tolerance if that's a good
thing but tolerance says if you
disappear off the face of the earth if
you're that person at a party you just
disappear we'd be better off you know or
I wouldn't be worse off because I was
just tolerating you but this country as
our founders said in the Declaration of
Independence pledging to each other an
irrational commitment this country says
we we were not called for tolerance
we're called for love to move beyond
tolerance to that because love always
sees worth sees dignity sees value and
the other person and knows actually that
if your kids do well if your kids become
an entrepreneur or an artist or a
teacher my kids are gonna benefit from
that that that that that is what makes a
great society and we cannot tolerate
each other we cannot tolerate divisions
we have to find ways to stitch this
country together with love
and so my request to everybody listening
is you could be fervently against a
Republican you could be fervently
against a Democrat you could be
fervently against those people who are
marching in the streets or what-have-you
my request is is that we all try to all
of us including me starting with me try
to see each other our humanity our
dignity and and try to love each other
just I see you I love you and love it
demands a surrender of ego for a little
while it demands and a courageous
empathy if we've talked about it demands
a a surrender of your position not
always but for a moment let me imagine
what it's like to you it love demands
you learning about somebody else like
how can I really I love my I restore my
Jewish American colleagues have I taken
the time to learn about the Irish
experience in America which is one of
the great stories of America the
japanese-american experience within a
great story of America have I learned
about you so you know this idea people
always say the biblical sense of knowing
each other but love not not eros love
but love agape love necessitates
knowledge knowing one another as well
and so I guess that's a long-winded way
of saying my request for all of us for
people that you think you disagree with
take time to see them and to feel in
your heart a love that Americans should
feel to each other don't have to agree
with each other always like each other
but do you sincerely believe that
patriotism obliges you to love Americans
and if it does then really try to love
which is not a being verb it's an active
word it necessitates us acting towards
our neighbor with a certain level of
commitment I think that's the perfect
place to end Cory thank you so much
thank you for taking the time blown away
that you would have me on oh it's great
to see you again and I hope that we
don't go as long before the next time we
see each other so thank you again I
really appreciate the entire team thank
you and I'll say this one more time you
are one of the sources of inspiration in
my life and more more than just
inspiration education I've learned a lot
from you as a as a guy I see you
appear but in many ways you are one of
the teachers of my life and I appreciate
you
professor Faris thank you Thank You Cory
well you said you were a Padawan I won't
point earlier I think you're definitely
in that teacher role and certainly in
that leadership role so this is this is
a conversation I hope we can we can
continue and for everybody listening as
always you can find the show notes for
this episode links to all of the books
documentaries and many other things
mentioned at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast you can find links to these show
notes for all other episodes there and
until next time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday then that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
in this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I ended
up meeting with the CEO not very long
ago why are they so popular well they
are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of my friend of oz and
beyond you can take pictures of receipts
you can link your credit card and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically
here in your fresh books in the right
category so on and so forth makes taxes
easy makes invoices easy makes your life
easier and also in fact I recommend a
PDF they didn't ask me to read this part
by the way they put the other PDF a
while back called breaking the time
barrier subtitle how to unlock your true
earning potential so you can search for
breaking the time barrier a lot of
people ask me how can I get a 4-hour
workweek with a service business and the
story in that ebook its PDF is the short
answer it's really really good so I
think you should also check that out so
breaking the time error check it out but
also why not test out fresh books claim
your 30-day unrestricted free trial at
fresh ebooks.com forward slash tim and
enter tim ferriss two hours in two S's
in the how did you hear about us section
that sounds like we're gonna get very
little tracking that's a lot of work but
just go to fresh books calm forward
slash tim and try it out because it is a
very good product and i think you will
find it simplifies your life enjoy this
episode's brought to you by XO protein
that's XO like the exoskeleton in aliens
and they make the only bars meal
replacement bars or pre-workout bars in
my case that i have in my house you can
hear the crinkling of cocoa nut which
i'm going to get back to they're making
protein bars using cricket protein
powder and many of the crossfit mutants
and high-performance out there are
eating these I am also eating them
generally pre-workout and I bet they
taste better than any protein bar you've
ever had and why is that just one of the
benefits while they are exceptionally
high in complete protein they are
minimally processed much less processed
than most say whey protein isolate and
packed full of nutrients including
calcium omega-3s and so on for those
people who are interested also very
sustainable so this is part of the
reason I ended up investing in the
company the United Nations estimates
that crickets are 20 times more resource
efficient per pound of protein than cows
for instance XO protein was created by a
three Michelin star chef and two Ivy
League grads they have made a line of
protein bars that will I think really
blow your mind
and some of my friends were journalists
have even tested them with glucose
monitors to see what the glucose
response is because they have a little
bit of carbs in them and it was flatline
provoked no huge glucose or insulin
response whatsoever
so there you go you have that they
combined the cricket protein with simple
ingredients like cocoa almond butter and
so on to create a bar that takes just
about every box you could possibly care
about their paleo gluten free soy free
dairy free low glycemic no refined sugar
the list goes on
they are my go-to bars and for all of
you guys listening EXO is offering a
sampler pack of their four most popular
flavors for less than ten dollars while
supplies last and that's not an
infomercial while supplies last the last
time they're on the podcast this sold
out in about a week so I recommend you
check it out their start up very limited
supplies go to XO protein com
EXO p ro te am compote in and you can be
one of the first to try the future of
protein so check it out XO protein com
forward slash temp
you